[Musique]
vous la connaissez cette bande c'est pas
une bourde est quand même des mecs qui
bossent ensemble
raymond descout
ils vont là où il ya du fric braquo chip
cox ils ont bien compris le monde dans
lequel on vit
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passait mal
tous voient personne
parce que tu sais qui vous a tiré dessus
je pars pas où était cachée sans matt et
-29 toulon qui parlent d'autres disent
que c'est toi qui fais moi
il faut que tu trouves qui a fait ça
genou qui ne pourra pas faire taire les
rumeurs médias me on a grandi au même
endroit pas le même qu'à toi ça va pas
forcément dire qu'on est m
je te promets je vais manger
[Musique]
voir aussi du mot ce que tu attendes moi
je le fais tu continues le deal avec les
as tu du lac avec les ânes et washington
ont été rares
un thème c'est jouer avec les genres
[Applaudissements]